life here is bad at the best of times
but it is now desperate and on the brink
of crisis
as many as three million refugees are
surviving in these conditions
they are living in heavy snow and
freezing temperatures we just canvassed
tents to protect them from the weather
yeah and many of those tents have
collapsed under the weight of the snow
and ice
they're forced to burn anything they can
to stay warm and cook hot food
dry wood if they can find it but often
they have no choice but to burn plastic
which sends toxic fumes into the tent
and makes children in particular very
sick
it is a fight against the elements
and a fight that they are losing
all the floor has water look at night it
is too cold the water comes from here
the cold was too much for muhammad's
baby daughter one night he shows our
team a photo of her on his phone
he tells us he woke up in the morning to
find her as stiff as wood i know i must
observe we took her to a clinic that
transferred us to the hospital they
called seven to eight ambulance carts
but unfortunately no car came so i was
angry and i took her by motorbike as it
was raining
my wife stayed at the hospital at 4 am
she called me that the doctor said your
daughter died in the morning i went
there i took her and brought her by
motorbike
the local hospitals many of them
destroyed by war are full and struggling
to treat the huge number of sick
children who need help
most of the kids who come to the
hospital are from the camps especially
the ones who are one day old in two
months they come in a state of
suffocation or semi-suffocation caused
by bronchitis in addition to the use of
waste or plastic materials for heating
tents
the united nations says that more
funding and help is needed
as is a long-term solution for them we
need much more funding but we also need
better access and more political well
will to you know to help provide
safer and more dignified temporary
accommodation for these people i say
temporary because in the longer term
what is really needed is a political
solution and for peace and stability in
the region that's what people want
they've spent years living in tents on
the run from the violence that has
destroyed so much of syria
the fact is it has been going on for so
long now
that the world has virtually forgotten
aleister bungle sky news
you